I came to sit after studying walls and I
had this whole physicality yeah and I
was doing like a rehearsal in the
director goes what are you doing with
your body man and I said oh you know I
was just thinking the wolves are like
they're always smelling and they're
looking down because they're actually
smelling the ground and goes wolves
you're a Wolverine I said what there's
no such thing and he goes yeah there is
go to the zoo down the road man there's
a whole there's four of them down there
[Music]
I think everybody winds up for the most
part getting the jobs they're supposed
to get and the rest of it is sour grapes
and why isn't this happening for me and
oh you know I only get the stuff he
turns down it's really kind of more of a
world view and right before Iron Man and
the screen test for that there was part
of me that was saying my world view has
to change if I want to really have a
shot you know if I'm not on my side for
this going my way why should anybody
else be and I'm not saying that's really
what made the difference but there is a
bit of Destiny involved in a lot of this
stuff so you mean you kind of willed
yourself to change your attitude you
said hey I'm going in for an audition
for this movie I really want Iron Man
I'm going in for favro I want to make
sure that these guys and [ __ ] all the
other actors and they're saying I I have
to come in here and make it my part is
that what you're saying you can't be
sour grapes you can't say oh woe is me
no I haven't really done it since but
for that one instant I had to psych
myself into to that there was no nobody
else on Earth had a chance I was too
prepared I was too confident was it a
great audition in your opinion I I think
yeah obviously it went pretty well but
that's the funny thing about confidence
too is confidence if you the incorrect
amount of it and nothing will ever
happen
staying in the pocket with it for a
while only lasts so long you even have
to transcend that because it's still
because everyone goes like oh man you
know you uh Tony Stark is so confident
and you know you must be that confident
and I'm like I'm betraying someone who's
is a very kind of broken guy but his
facade is that he's confident so to say
that I'm just the facade is the kind of
short Change how human we all are
explain this to me because I'm not an
actor and I don't understand how you
develop a character are you telling me
that when you go in it and it's a comic
book you know it's Tony Stark is this
character right and you can read the
comic book but would you go and study a
confident Tycoon and kind of take on his
Persona is that a way of getting to that
character I was just thinking this is me
and I am in this situation that's what
you do absolutely I am a tycoon I'm
brilliant yeah and how would I behave if
I was that guy I was driving like you
know a beat up used old car there and I
was you know I I had the nicest suit I
had to to put on but I was if you'd
asked me how it arrived that would have
said in a convoy of rolls-royces it's
not an impression it's you as an
imagining yourself as a super success
yeah in this instance other times it's
it's different I don't really I don't
really have a method or a process that I
use but I know that when whatever's
going to work for that role or whatever
when it hits me I know it
s audition for uh Dream Girls and
Fantasia Barina who won that year she
was also up for Dream Girls right and
you probably said psychologically oh my
God she won so they're probably going to
choose her right that was you you
probably went in there thinking at the
time I probably didn't know until like
at the very tail end of the audition
because it took six months right to get
the role and it was 782 other people
other than myself that audition they
like we searched like the world don't
you think even
um she had the advantage going in on
that audition because everyone's like
hey why should we pick the seventh let's
pick number one yeah she's got the most
name recognition it certainly would be a
marketing yeah Whoever has the producers
what it was you did that got you I'll
tell you Bill Clinton said I was the
only person he felt something from and
he really like he had you know he he
felt chills like he really felt it how
do you prepare for an audition like that
like what do you do do you get the pages
and you or do you just go in and sing
that uh one of those famous songs yeah
oh my god well I mean again in it I went
through three different auditions and
the first audition it was the song the
song but it was only half the song
because they messed up the sheet music
and so I learned it that way right and
then I went in and I heard another lady
audition and I'm like wait we're here
for the same thing she's singing the
whole song right I only got half of it
but I wanted to be a professional you
know and I didn't want to complain or
say anything so I was like I'm gonna go
in there and I'm gonna just try to like
just sing it and I blew the audition I
completely messed it up because you
didn't have the right because I didn't
have the right she music and they're not
interested in your excuses either they
just wanted to give excuses I learned
that from Idol yeah did you think there
was curtains for you at that point
um I didn't know I didn't know but
luckily they found out that they missed
mixed up the sheet music and even with
me you know messing up they were still
like no it's something there there's
something they want to see her again so
when you come in again do they have you
do the song over again they
I think at that point I had I know I had
a scene and then they requested that I
sing another song that was like in place
of random and I am telling you but like
the same I guess subtext right and so I
did easy to be hard
I did that song which is like uh from
hair right
um and they like got it and then there's
a third audition they're still not sure
oh God they made us wait to the last
second day did you want that movie more
than you wanted to win American Idol oh
God yes because again who gets a second
chance and then that big like so and
then it was a a dream role you know like
I didn't know much of the play but I
knew the music and I was like God I want
to sing this music you know because even
when I was on idol Barry Manilow had
arranged one of the songs
um weekend in New England as if it was
and I'm telling you so people looked at
that and was like she reminds us of
Effie so when that's why they all came
up everybody was like Jennifer Hudson
for Effie I didn't even know the
character name I was like who is it who
is this effort what are they talking
about I don't know any efforts yeah and
to this day people still think that I
was singing and I'm telling you on the
show and I was like no it was weekend in
New England that was arranged like NFL
you know one of the things I love about
your a story is that really that was
supposed to be let's be honest that was
supposed to be Beyonce's movie did
everyone on that set sense that it was
becoming your movie they used to all say
it I didn't understand and they would
tell me that they're like you have the
amazing thing is you have no clue what's
going on and like Jamie Foxx he sat me
down and he was like you know you're
gonna win an Oscar for this and the
whole set started to say it and Beyonce
we were in the studio one time and she
was like you do realize no one gets a a
start like this right before Walking
Dead I auditioned for one of these shows
that uh it's a
it's like one of these uh procedural
shows that's been going on forever you
you got the part too right I got the
part what show was that uh I think it
was ncisla okay so that's a good show
it's a good gig because right yeah it's
a franchise yeah but you think The
Walking Dead script is so good that you
tell the NCIS uh show that uh hey wait a
second I I can't take this job I have to
wait and see what the walking dead it's
not even see I hadn't even auditioned
for Walking Dead you gotta understand at
this point in my career getting you know
getting cast in The Walking Dead I mean
it was moved I don't know if it was
ballsy I I think you know my old man
thought it was the stupidest move I ever
made you know you're never gonna have to
worry about money again but I read this
script and I in my heart I knew it was
something enormously special and and I
really wanted to do it it was one of
those jobs that I wanted to be Shane you
know that he he the way that that whole
well the way I heard it yes sir in the
audition uh a bunch of you guys audition
for wreck audition for Shane audition
for like it was a bunch of the guys and
uh you don't know really what part
you're gonna get right you could have
ended up being Rick you know everybody
had to audition for Rick first right and
you know in in these Hollywood screen
tests man they're they're they're the
most kind of artificial they're not
really conducive for for people's best
performances you know and and the way
that Frank darabon did it is he got 10
guys and everybody had to read for both
roles he said no network Executives can
be there he uh you know usually you do
it in a room in front of a bunch of
people in suits and it's completely
artificial but he did it he rented out
of soundstage he got a real police car
he rigged it for sound he lit it and we
all spent the day together all these
guys I remember pulling up to that
audition and seeing this one guy sort of
like leaning on his uh Ford Mustang with
sunglasses and I was like that's the
handsomest [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my life there's no way this guy is
not going to get this part you know what
I mean with my ugly ass you know and uh
you know it was one of those days where
you know people started to unravel by
the end because everybody really wanted
the job and I remember one guy
particular he was uh he was we did the
scene and then Frank Darabont walked
over I mean it's Frank darabon he walks
over and uh
he says yeah the scene was great but you
need to take your gum out you know you
just let's do it again without gum the
guy takes his gum out and hands it to
Frank Darrell I mean can you imagine
going to a job right now I think you I
just really got to see how unnerved and
how rattled people get you know when you
really want something and like you said
you wanted to be Shane it opened up so
many doors I was I was grateful
when you get your first movie Dazed and
Confused I mean your first big thing and
the movie was a big movie you like just
kind of decided to be an actor because
you meet some guy in a bar well guy
bartender says the guy that the the end
of the uh bars in town producing a film
so I go introduce myself right my name
is Don Phillips what'd you say to Don
Phillips I said I introduced myself and
I said are you in town working on a film
he goes yeah yeah I'm working on this
film producing and I'm casting it's
called days confused what do you want
and so he was kind of off-putting the
meal right he's stupid what do you want
so we started shooting the [ __ ] and all
of a sudden we we both knew we played
golf we had a similar course we had
played cut to three hours later we get
kicked out right um forbidden little
rambunctious and on the ride home in
attacks he says hey Matt Matthew you
ever done any acting any of that acting
stunning acting if you know Don Phillips
people have to go this is what he said
it was like but and he's and I said well
I was in a Middle Light commercial for
about that long yeah I'd say it was more
of a modeling job for a half a second
and he goes we'll come to this address
in the morning if you're interested you
might be just right for this part I go
down pick up the script the day's
confused yeah and Richard linklater was
the director and so he meets with you
right I go home there's three lines I go
home and back to Longview Texas and work
on these three lines for three weeks
what were the three lines you even
remember well one's the one's a great
line the law I call it a launch pad line
right where you get a line like this and
you go oh there's a there's a whole
[ __ ] book on this character and it's
a guy it's wooderson out front of the
pool hall the girls walk by he reaches
over he slaps one on the back side as
she passes and his buddy says you're
gonna go to jail for that you got to cut
that out and he says no man
I keep getting older but they stay the
same age
you get a line like that philosopher
whoa yeah you know you're like genius so
as soon as I get that line I'm like who
is this cat right and you know you could
write a book on somebody if they believe
that and so I ended up working three
weeks yeah but when you got the
interview with this guy link later he
says to you hey you're not this guy yeah
so I come in
and it's a job interview right so I
shave through my hair iron my shirt
gotta have a pleat in my jeans tucked in
and everything about my job yeah I walk
in he's like yeah you're here to read
for what are some like yes sir and he's
like okay well then I sat down in this
Rick tells me said I sat in the chair
and he goes okay go ahead and he said I
kind of just kicked back and laid my
shoulders back and did Wilson he comes
up he goes well you're not this guy I
said no I'm not this guy but I know who
this guy is right and the two I thought
my middle brother was when I was 11 and
he was 17. and it was through the back
window of my mom's car going to pick him
up from school one day because his car
was broke down and she's looking for him
outside the school and he's not there
he's supposed to be well I see him at
the back window leaning against the wall
knee out foot up against the wall smoke
a cigarette in the smoking section
that's the guy he was seven he was the
coolest right and I go very and I
remember shutting up because he'd got
his ass beat for smoking right I didn't
tell Mom there he was but that image as
we pulled away watching my brother so in
other words only in acting should you
not walk in for your job interview all
cleanly shaved and groomed when I walked
away do you have a briefcase yeah
you were watching Curb Your Enthusiasm
had already been on for a couple of
Seasons you turned to your wife and you
said hey I should be on this show this
is good she even said that she agreed
right you go in for an audition you knew
Larry from your day's writing and
Saturday live you walk in and you see
Larry standing there for the audition I
walk into the room as the character
I don't [ __ ] walk in the room as JB
and say I'm JB smooth I'm about to play
the role of Leon and then turn [ __ ]
Leon on that's [ __ ] see that means
you got to change gears now you got to
get into your [ __ ] zone why not get
into the Zone in the [ __ ] waiting
room right already start doing the I
started doing mannerisms I said I know
who the [ __ ] this dude is right so I
read the sides I said I know who the
[ __ ] Leon is I know a few Leons hell
right I feel it's a lean on that my
[ __ ] house you know what I mean
who is Leon who is he really when you
when you sat there before you went into
the audition you had read the script or
a loose kind of idea of what this guy is
who was Leon this character that you
were about to portray Leon was a guy I
felt like a guy who lived day to day
he's a someone of an opportunist but
he's a guy that got your back
[ __ ] house you drove the car look
what you did to the car I'll tell you
something this [ __ ] car I got
some heart man I was surprised I thought
it was a [ __ ] ass car this [ __ ] got
some [ __ ] heart to it when I walk
into the room as Leon these
[ __ ] you should have seen a
face on these [ __ ] everybody
looked confused like what the [ __ ] just
happened what the [ __ ] is this dude
right and why is it coming in like this
you know what I mean yeah I can see it
in their faces they were like they
looked at each other like what the [ __ ]
is going on here I came in here like
this they told me I said okay okay you
don't improv Larry directly so I walked
up to Larry this is the [ __ ] I said as
character I said okay Larry let's do
this [ __ ] go to improv right okay let's
make it happen so I don't know this is
[ __ ] improv I might [ __ ] around
and slap you in the face I don't know
anything could happen right Larry's face
was like what the [ __ ]
other producers like get this
[ __ ] out of here
but I want it back see I wanted that see
what that does is this it allows those
producers those directors to see the
character immediately did they
understand what you were doing they
caught on because once I sat down and I
and I did my little Leon head tilt yeah
and I did some [ __ ] like this they got
it they [ __ ] started laughing their
asses off did they offer you the part
right then and there or the [ __ ] no no
they made you wait no no of course they
made me wait but here's the thing that
does
they told me after the fact that they
didn't know who Leon was until I walked
in the room I mean you had your take on
it and which is great because what that
was they said you didn't even open they
told me that you didn't even open your
mouth yet right you [ __ ] got it but
that's the power of mannerisms That's
The Power of improv That's The Power of
not going in that [ __ ] with a
goddamn plan because you stuck to that
goddamn plan and a plan only works one
[ __ ] time
it's one thing to be in NWA one thing to
go off on a solo career John Singleton
the filmmaker yes decides to put you yes
in boys in the hood yes now was this
something you ever believed in your
lifetime that you could have a movie
career not at all I had a Singleton know
that ice cube could be good in a movie
he was an intern at The Arsenio Hall
Show and really yeah I was up there
because I wanted to talk you know I was
up there to talk to Arsenio because I
wanted him to have you know easy in NWA
on because he had just had Luke two Live
Crew ons I'm like dude if you can have
them doing Pop That Coochie like you can
have us doing one express yourself so uh
Here Comes John Singleton you know he's
like an intern intern
yo your Cube huh yeah yeah what's up man
watch out what's up you know and he's
like yo man you know look I'm I'm a
junior at USC great and you perfect for
my move
huh you should come and [ __ ] off I I was
this close to it but he was so cool and
he was helping me navigate through you
know trying to get to our city you know
he was like yo he comes past here you
might talk to him yeah yeah so we get to
talking and he's telling me about this
script and I'm like dude whatever so
when he told you the script and you're
hearing it from an intern at the Arsenio
show are you like this is such a shitty
script no I'm like dude I just don't
believe him right you know what I'm
saying he sounds irresponsible to even
bring it up yeah it's like for one your
Junior UFC you don't have a movie I'm
not even an actor and you're coming to
me talking about I'm perfect for it we
both we all crazy in here right so
everyone associated with this is nuts
everybody's nuts what made you do it uh
I mean his persistence really I've seen
him a year later he ran up dude hey
remember me like no who are you oh yeah
you know you the Arsenal Hall Show uh
I'm a senior now and look he's still
perfect for my mom
so really how does he close the deal
with you because you're a pretty
successful artist at this point you got
solo career you had NWA but but no one
you've never been in a movie no well
here's what happened you know my manager
tells me one day somebody want to put
you in a movie I had forgot about this
dude I mean I'm like of course laser
focus on my career and I'm like I want
to put me in a movie yeah somebody want
to put you in a movie I'm like all right
cool give me the size and give me the
script right she gave me the script
threw the script in my backseat took the
size put them in my pocket and rolled
out so I went to the audition so I
didn't know who these people were I walk
in and it's him
remember me I'm like damn you you you
know it's a production now I'm like damn
you was it was real you wasn't
bullshitting he was like yeah man I
graduated and you perfect for my movie
right I auditioned I'm terrible I mean I
suck right I didn't read the script I
didn't read the sides I suck and he's
worried he's like oh [ __ ] I've been
chasing a guy here
so he said look man did you read my
script I said nah I didn't read it I
didn't read it he said I'll give you one
more shot you go home read my script and
when you come back if you if you're good
you're good if not I'm gonna have to
cast somebody else in your role so I
went and read the script and then you
know I had this Epiphany like oh [ __ ]
right this is about our neighborhood
this is something I know I can do yes so
when I went back in I took it serious
from then on from that day on I've been
taking filmmaking and auditioning and
acting seriously
Almost Famous for such a good movie and
you got nominated for an Academy Award
and everything which is unbelievable
since like the yucky had only done like
one other film and then you got that
film right and yeah you had to audition
for that I assume yeah like four times
and tons of people wanted that right I
mean yeah it was that that was a that
was a uh I I was actually I was shooting
in in um in Ireland another film at the
time and I kept flying back and forth to
uh to audition and yeah and I finally
yeah I'll never forget that phone call
but when I got the part yeah because I
was supposed to play a different role I
was supposed to play the sister not
Penny Lane and Cameron didn't want me to
audition so because he just saw me as a
sister right and I just said look I'm
and then everybody fell out of the movie
because at the time I got the sister it
was Brad Pitt and Sarah Paulie really
and I was turning down other parts and
things and Cameron and I said just
please I'm gonna be in the movie night
but just please let me audition why
because you sensed that it would big
Commercial Success no I just love
Cameron Crowe I loved his movies they to
me like singles and say anything and and
and Jerry Maguire I mean to be in to be
in his next film was like a you know
please
were you nervous when you got on set for
that movie
I think you're always a little bit
nervous and then and then you're oh yeah
you get I mean you get anxiety it's like
coming in here you get a little bit like
uh-oh and then you sort of start to like
you know get a little more comfortable
yeah but you don't want to get too
comfortable look at the list of people
who were up for that role this is it I
don't know if you ever heard this so
maybe it's not even true because you
just read this stuff okay uh Kate
Campbell Jenna Elfman Bridget Moynihan
Maggie Gyllenhaal Rose McGowan Rebecca
Romaine auditioned for the role of Penny
Lane and you beat them all is there some
sort of like competitive
um I don't know pride in all of that you
know I think when you grow up like with
parents like I did competitiveness in
this world is like a No-No like you get
it right away you know you don't think
it was hard for your mother and maybe
even Kurt when you got nominated for an
Academy Award no I think they were they
were relieved very you know what that's
that's interesting yeah probably you're
probably worried about it there was
probably a relief of like you know
you know maybe the relief was like she's
pretty good right not just validation
right yes Russell Crowe yeah was the
original they wanted him to be Wolverine
is that true absolutely and Russell
Crowe called you and said hey you ought
to go in on this part he didn't tell
Comey he called Brian Brian Singer the
director he said Alexa I don't want to
do it but you should look at this guy
right and I was doing Oklahoma at the
time my hair looked like yours man I had
a sperm in my hair you had a fro when I
went for the Wolverine audition I had to
put a baseball cap on and the casting
agent said uh I don't think the baseball
cap for Wolverine I took it off I guess
here put it back on yeah it was so weird
isn't it because here you know first of
all you have the Australian accent you
know there was a lot they had to
overlook or or take a leap of faith when
he was Wolverine plus you knew nothing
about Wolverine you thought you thought
it was about wolves you thought you were
playing I didn't even know I'd never
heard of X-Men I didn't know there was
an animal called a Wolverine I thought
it was like of those Shazam it's a
made-up like comic book animal or
something and I came to sit after
studying wolves and I had this whole
physicality yeah and I was doing like a
rehearsal in the direction because what
are you doing with your body man and I
said oh you know I was just thinking the
Wolves Away they're always smelling and
they're looking down because they're
actually smelling the ground and he goes
wolves you're a Wolverine I said well
there's no such thing and he goes yeah
there is go to the zoo down the road man
there's a whole there's four of them
down there what did you do you walked
around I know your wife told you not to
take the part because she said don't do
the audition yeah she did the Royal
National Theater and you've got freaking
claws coming out of your hands but you
know but she's going off three pages
right and by the way this is the only
time Deborah's ever been wrong
good advisor yeah but I went for the
audition and uh I I said yeah but Anna
Paquin this is Ian McKellen Patrick
Stewart yeah you know the director of
Usual Suspects I said there's got to be
more to this yeah I'd only read three
pages to but isn't the motto or not the
moral of the story that as a as a
performer as an actor you gotta act you
can't you don't know with these films
you don't really have a crystal ball to
know that you're gonna end up are you
the longest running in a series I think
the only other guy is Sean Connery who'd
played James Bond yeah but you playing a
continuing character in the movies yeah
you're one you have the most longevity
as uh Wolverine yeah and it's brilliant
why not no I and yeah I I always had a
young actors like I don't know about
doing this I said Say Yes Man yes
Michael kein's the best so Michael Kane
always said he goes look one in ten
things you do is a success everything
else is a failure so just say yes to
everything right and just make sure you
got 10 things